in early 2021 the san diego county
district attorney offered up then police
officer matthew dagus
as kind of a sacrificial lamb to appease
blm radicals
they charged him with the excessive use
of force and gave the liberal mob
license to make hell
a life hell for him and his family for
more on that we turn to fox's matt finn
matt
laura matthew degas is a former police
officer here in southern california in
la mesa he and his wife say the liberal
politicians of la mesa put them through
quote the fires of hell for a 2020
arrest video showing degas appear to use
a very low level of force to arrest a
combative man police officer matthew
dagus is questioning the black man in a
basketball jersey body camera video
shows the man swipe at or slap dagus
degas grabs the man's shirt forces him
to sit down and then instructs him he's
going to be arrested
bro i didn't put nothing on you bro it's
on camera so you can check me listen
bro y'all hella goofy bro i'm talking to
you and you smacked me bro nobody
smacked you bro i smacked you you didn't
watch smack you you didn't snack you
didn't hit me
all right but why are you grabbing me
though you're being placed under arrest
for 241c okay yep all right what's the
241c that's also a peace officer the
incident happened in may 2020 around the
time of george floyd's murder this video
went viral with activists trying to
compare it to the floyd incident degus
and his wife say la mesa politicians
quote bowed to the mob using degus as a
scapegoat charging deguss with filing a
false police report to arrest the
suspect however a california jury
ultimately found matthew degas not
guilty of that felony charge degas says
the trial cost him close to 100 thousand
dollars and now he's looking to get his
job back laura
wow thanks for that update matt joining
me now is matthew dagus former la mesa
police officer
matthew there was a frenzy
after the killing of george floyd in
this country
and you were part of that it looks like
has the city of la mesa apologized for
what they put you all through
no i mean unfortunately there's been no
apology given um but yeah i mean it was
quite a frenzy not only for me i think
but for all law enforcement officers
throughout the country
um during that time and still as it is
today now matthew i want to get into
specifically what happened to you and
your family as a result of these false
charges but
this is from security camera footage
outside of your home
you can see the blm protesters marching
matthew how often did that happen
and how did they know where you lived
well it never happens and that's i don't
think that's ever anything any police
officer expects to happen
[Music]
you know you as a police officer expect
that the danger is going to be in the
field so
when you go home at night uh
you want to feel safe obviously as
everyone does and you never expect to
have
a protest outside your house and quite
frankly it was it was terrifying
for my whole family so it was were they
screaming was it every night was it how
frequent was it
it was a couple of days and it it led
into that
wild weekend in may which you know
throughout the whole country uh where
the riots took place
um thankfully you know my family and i
were we were gone by then we we left the
house at that point so so they drove you
out of there wasn't a safe place did
they drive you out of the house is that
is that a fair statement
yeah i mean we ended up having to sell
the house as a result of that it's not
it wasn't a safe place for me to be in
order for my family to be anymore
wait a second
you had to sell your house
as criminals are
let free in a revolving door of madness
in california
a police officer driven from his house
that's correct unfortunately it was uh
you know no longer a safe spot you're
you know you never think that your home
is going to be uh
somewhere that is going to be under
attack
at this point how much
have you lost
because of this
i mean financially how much have you
lost professionally what have you lost
emotionally
i mean i describe it to people that
i've lost everything to be honest i've
lost my career
my family was
you know under this uh terror for the
last you know year and a half now
thankfully we've come out victorious on
that end um but you know and also on top
of that i think we're me and my wife are
set back about 100 000 in legal fees so
you know we've we've been put through
the ringer uh you know in the name of i
guess
justice
well we're showing video of what
happened
after that incident i mean there was
massive protests
lots of chaos
in la mesa
as we saw all across the country at that
time
i'm thinking of you and your family i
want to figure out a way to do something
for you guys
we'll have to figure that out how that
can be organized but
are do you have a job are you able to
work now you have to tell us where
you're working but you have a way to
support yourself after all this
i'm still not working
my focus is getting back into uniform
and that's something that you know i
have and still am doing
my wife and i are fighting to uh to do
that we still are going through the
court process to get me reinstated
to get my back pay to get
basically my life back and to really
clear my name from any wrongdoing here
okay matthew this is just going to have
to be rectified and we're going to try
to help you do that i mean this is this
just can't happen in the united states
this is absolutely insane and i know the
country watching this is with you
tonight your family
it's going to work out but thank you for
your service and we're going to be
following this and i'll be in touch with
you offline this is ridiculous this
can't be our country hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else